it was shortly after delivering a eulogy
at the memorial service for former
president f w de clarke when south
african president sular maposa fell ill
he is one of more than 18 thousand
people in the country who have
contracted covert 19 in the past 24
hours
the government says the president is
suffering mild symptoms and is being
monitored
those who've had close contact with
ramaphosa have been told to isolate in a
tweet issued by the president while
thanking people for their support he
urged all south africans to get
vaccinated
so far 43 percent of eligible south
africans have received at least one jab
while there is enough stock available
including booster shots many people are
still reluctant to get a jab the
government says it's trying to dispel
misinformation and create greater
awareness about the importance of being
vaccinated
but many other countries in africa have
not had the same access to vaccines
just seven percent of africa's more than
one billion population has been
inoculated against
have coronavirus really been
disappointed
in the approach that the rich countries
have taken on the issue of vaccines
firstly they hoarded our seeds
they ordered more vaccines than their
populations required
and when we wanted vaccines
they just kept you know giving us the
crumbs from their table
in the last week an average of 19 000
south africans have been infected every
day
health experts say the surge could be
driven by the new omicron variant but
although they say it's highly contagious
preliminary data indicates it may not
cause severe illness
and while the government may be directed
by science a fully vaccinated but ill
president may do little to reassure
those already skeptical of being jabbed
family al jazeera johannesburg